I don't like 20 situations and could
have got killed long before the music
started
if you could go back in time
and give young Curtis one piece of
advice what would it be
I would have started writing music way
early
I wouldn't even I'd have skipped all of
the stuff that I could have possibly
because all of this could have changed
well I think that is just your character
though so it did
turn into my behaviors
and the music the things you go to make
who you are there's more Ruthless People
in the business world than in the street
you know like they just have subtleties
to their tactics how they do things is
it's more you know but they're doing it
right and funny you know how to
structure and the actual deal and things
that they're doing it's like just taking
the money for you look robbery at least
it will give give you the courtesy of
showing you to God so you can have those
anxieties and feel those feelings that
you would feel when you're being robbed
they'll do it on a piece of paper where
you feel nothing and just rob you right
there you see what I'm saying so it's
the same tactics but a different
approach
and a lot of them the people that do
this comfortably because I can't use the
contract the thing that they're not
condition for is direct conflict and
that the circumstances I grew under are
absolutely have to be prepared for this
positive influences there's negative
influences there's a lot of things
around that you can actually do like
look at YouTube
it's pretty much every skill set you're
looking for you can find on YouTube
do find some information about what
you're trying to do and not even have it
be something for you to sit and read you
what just watching them explain it you
know so I don't know why you're not it's
not clearer that there's less
limitations like they're not limited the
same way
you were in the past you know what I
mean okay now how did you become
interested in Vitamin Water I was in a
supermarket and I saw a gallon of water
for 289 and I went further down the
island I sent another gallon spring
water for 59
and I just know that if you put that in
these two different cups that we have in
front of us that I wouldn't know the
difference between what spring it came
from
when I got back I told Chris at the time
me and Chris Lighty was working closely
together he was managing me and I said
uh I want to sell water
I think it's like like what
I said I want to say what he's like the
who everybody need water like you know
it might have been an easier concept for
him if I said I wanted to sell liquor so
you bought the company now so I ended up
having about almost 10 percent of it
and it was sold to Coca-Cola for
100 you made 100 million well 4.1
billion they actually sold a company for
I've somehow ended up on the
circumstances where I've been up against
the toughest things in the environment
that I come out of before any success
takes place I always say if there was
someone someone to run and go get I
would have ran and got them but I have
to run get me so I had to come back
myself every time so it just makes me
not look at what would be the great the
bigger situations in front of me the
harder circumstances don't seem so rough
to me no more you know like because I've
already been up against the toughest
things the biggest obstacles take this
for granted right almost 90 of the time
I'm communicating with people who
achieved a higher level of Education
all right the college graduates things
like that and um
what I hold on to is there was an
amazing the circumstances that I came up
on
and
you know if the information that you
needed
in the business classes were
in the book If everything you needed was
in the book
then the teacher would be too successful
to teach the class
it's how you adjust today so I think
when
because you have Peaks and valleys or
have things change in your career at the
point and you feel like is it at Ohio is
it how long you don't can't even
because money is still coming in you
don't feel like there's a change in
financial stuff like but you'll see
things that you go wait I don't
understand why they're doing this
even now in film intelligence I look
around and go wait what is this like I
don't know what they're doing
like why'd they pick this up
if if I don't understand what's going on
then I'm not sure I'm as good as I think
I am
right if you if you're confused that how
the operation is is working
then you don't know if everything I
picked is working
what's so great about that but you go
what what is all the other stuff that
they're picking right what is that like
how much does that equate to as far as
the audience that they have at the
network or why why are they doing it
you know and just trying to understand
that because I guess eventually
I'll be the network without knowing who
you are individually look and just judge
you and say I don't like that he had
that diamond goat on his neck why'd he
put that dick
you got to be a certain kind of person
because he liked diamonds all right and
then they could just assume that you
anything they would like to register
Negative they can just register it
negative some people they have the uh
the trader at the state of persons
across the street that look at you they
don't like you across the street some
people feel like the need to go across
the street to say why I'm a good person
I don't give a yeah I genuinely don't
give about all those people forget about
me across the street because they don't
care about me
having the ability to focus on something
on the work on it will allow you to work
hard enough to be good enough at it
that's one thing when you can actually
commit to yourself and what you want for
your life and you work that hard at it
this is watching someone else raise
their hand to answer a question that
they know the answer to
and that means that person deserves to
be ahead of you in life because your
fear of being wrong
at that point is not allowing you to
create your value in the workspace
well when you're in life-threatening
situations it makes you a little more
conscious of that
you know and the more that you
are aware of your state
the higher the probability you have a
chance to live
[Music]
so you're a little more free
so
walking into a room even at the worst
possible uh scenario it won't damage me
to the point or hurt as much as that
hurt it started going in in a secure
space able to speak and ask the
questions and I'd rather
be feel like I'm unaware for the moment
within that those quarters then they
feel like I'm unaware and are losing
situation
so I don't regret those things I don't
regret them because I don't think I'd be
who I am today
if I wasn't exposed to those situations
if you asked me would I
those are unfortunate situations that
I've had to experience and if I had a
choice I would have definitely went in a
different direction but under those
circumstances when when you're an
environment where you meet aggression
with aggression or you're deemed weak
and the weak becomes to pray
you had a
kind of back people off you at different
points and when you're willing to go as
far as
further
than the other guy you always Prevail
you always end up on top
even at this point
the person that you could have met fell
in love with how many positive moments
right your highlight bill that these are
really important the most expensive
thing we spend is time because we can't
get it back
and and when you look at the Highlight
Bill whether the person's Rich poor in
the middle wherever they're at right but
me personally I look at it and say they
still have so many moments look before I
had money
when I'm rich in the middle when I'm
poor when I'm in the middle when I'm
rich with regardless I've been on each
one of those portions of the journey
right
have fun
but we didn't have no money we had fun
was that the most fun it was fun now
it's a different kind of thing yeah so
we've been kind of fun and the when you
grow up without finances the uh you
start to view
Financial Freedom becomes really
important
you know you start to be conscious of
what you because the restraints the
biggest restraint is something that
costs right how much it costs I mean and
later you work yourself into a place
where you're not worrying about the cost
like what you're saying it's Elementary
right the building blocks that you put
down essentially if they keep moving you
can't build
right so I set certain rules there was
the basis
for how we would be productive I said
I don't care who you fight do not fight
someone that I came with
um
if you need to have some sort of dispute
or something going on y'all tell each
other with you right now get away from
me right you go back in the bus you stay
at the front of the bus whatever you
know you're upset you know your type but
you just stay away from y'all stay away
from each other
right because if you have the fight
you're both getting the [ __ ] out of here
you're going home
right and the reason why I was saying
this is I can't bring new people on
when the foundation that I had is
fighting each other
foreign